[Music]
it's a disturbing trend says US meteo
Dean a Muslim attorney in the New York
Times she says in recent years state
lawmakers lawyers and influential social
commentators have been making the case
that Muslims are not protected by the
First Amendment
why because they argue Islam is not a
religion what it is
say houdin's targets is a political
system she says John Bennett a
Republican state legislator in Oklahoma
said in 2014
Islam is not even a religion it is a
political system that uses a deity to
advance its agenda of global conquest in
2015 a former assistant United States
attorney Andrew C McCarthy wrote in
National Review that Islam should be
understood as conveying a belief system
that is not merely or even primarily
religious in 2016 Michael Flynn who the
next year was briefly president Trump's
national security adviser told an act
for America conference in Dallas that
Islam is a political ideology that hides
behind the notion of it being a religion
in a January 2018 news release Neil
Tapio of South Dakota a Republican state
senator who is planning to run for the
United States House of Representatives
questioned whether the First Amendment
applies to Muslims
all right look merriam-webster defines
religion as a personal set or
institutionalized system of religious
attitudes beliefs and practices Islam
certainly qualifies as a religion by
that definition religions profess to
connect human beings to the divine Islam
professes to do that at the same time
however it is also a political system
that is authoritarian supremacist
discriminatory expansionist violent and
aggressive Ozma Teague Dean must be
aware of these facts but she ignores
them entirely instead giving the
impression that sharia islamic law is
simply religious law and opposition to
Sharia is simply motivated by religious
bigotry and of course Islamophobia in
reality Islamic law is political aspect
contradict constitutional principles and
American freedoms in numerous
particulars including its denial of the
freedom of speech the institutionalized
discrimination against women non-muslims
and other groups its death penalty for
apostasy from Islam and for homosexual
activity and more at a certain point
there needs to be a national discussion
about whether religious freedom grants
Muslims the right to break other laws or
whether the aspects of Islamic law that
contradict American law are actually
unwelcome in the United States
Ozma Teague Dean in the New York Times
are trying to foreclose upon that
discussion by muddling the issue the
laws backers Udine claims seemed to see
them as necessary stopgaps to protect
against their imagined Muslim takeover
of America when an Idaho state
representative Eric Redmond a Republican
introduced his anti Sharia bill in
January he said it was needed so that
foreign law would not defile our
constitutional laws and to protect our
state and our country that's a similar
sentiments to the one expressed by the
conservative political activist Pamela
Geller who argued in a 2016 commentary
published by Breitbart that Muslim
women's seeking accommodations to wear a
headscarf in the workplace are part of a
Muslim effort to impose aslam on the
secular marketplace now Islam has always
been political its political aspect has
always been considered intrinsic to its
nature on this the historical record is
clear my book the history of jihad from
Muhammad to Isis shows definitively from
primary source material that everywhere
Islam has gone it has gone as a
political entity and waged war against
other political entities Ozma Teague
Dean and the New York Times are relying
upon you not knowing that and you're
ignorant of Islamic law and Islamic
history in order to manipulate you into
thinking that Sharia is benign and
compatible with the United States
character as a free society even though
every society where Sharia has ever been
implemented has not been free wherever
Sharia has been the law of the land
throughout Islamic history and today in
Saudi Arabia Iran and other areas of the
Islam
world it has had largely the same
character that character has never
resembled liberal democracy by any
stretch of the imagination
Sharia polities throughout history and
today have denied the freedom of speech
the freedom of conscience and they have
mandated discrimination against women
and non-muslims many non-muslims
mistakenly believe that relatively free
and westernized majority Muslim states
principally Turkey at least until
recently demonstrate the compatibility
of Sharia with understandings of human
rights that are otherwise universally
accepted that is however a fundamental
misapprehension turkey and other
relatively westernized Muslim countries
have not been governed by Sharia at all
but instead by legal codes imported from
the West
in fact Mustafa Kemal atatürk
established the modern-day Turkish
Republic as a defiant rejection of
Sharia and an explicit determination to
establish a western-style state free
from the strictures of Islamic law such
states don't have a different more
expansive version of Sharia they just
don't have Sharia at all this is the
focus of anti Sharia laws in reality to
prevent this authoritarian and
oppressive political and social system
from eroding the freedoms we enjoy as
Americans it is plainly disingenuous to
claim that anti Sharia laws would
infringe upon Muslims First Amendment
rights to practice their religion as
Thomas Jefferson said it does mean no
injury for my neighbor to say there are
20 gods or no God it neither fixed my
pocket nor breaks my leg only when your
religion believes his God commands him
to pick your pocket or break your leg do
his beliefs become a matter of concern
for those who do not share them no one
wants to restrict individual Muslim
religious practice or even cares about
it the purpose of anti Sharia laws is
not to stop Muslims from getting married
in Islamic religious ceremonies and the
like but to stop the political and
supremacist aspects of Islam that
infringe upon the rights and freedoms of
non-muslims
the Islamic state as delineated by
Sharia encroaches on the basic rights of
non
it would be a sad irony for non-muslims
to impose anti Sharia laws and thereby
abet their own subjugation the New York
Times is actively abetting that
subjugation
I'm Robert Spencer Shulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
[Music]